on continue on parle de politique
toujours Joel Réon n'est plus le maire
de plaisir après 12 années passées à la
tête de la ville nous allons revenir sur
cette soirée déjà qui a vu votre
élection Joséphine colmansberger retour
sur cette soirée donc richrich en
émotion avec ce sujet de la
rédaction je pars heureux content et euh
j'allais dire nourri mais vraiment très
fortement de tout ce que vous avez pu me
donner our de l'émotion dans la voix de
Joël réot lors du conseil municipal
extraordinaire du 15 novembre dernier
maire de la ville depuis 2001 il a
choisi de démissionner avant que la
lcitude ne s'installe selon ses propres
mots une longue ovation a suivi son
discours émue à ses côtés celle qui
devient donc la nouvelle mère de plaisir
Joséphine colmans berger le vote a été
sans surprise seule candidate l'ancienne
adjointe à la culture recueille 31 voix
on compte si bulletins blanc ou nul il
faut que je me fasse connaître des
Plaisirois parce que les Plaisirois me
connaissent en tant que délégué à la
culture et la communication mais en tant
que maire pas encore donc je vais faire
mon bonhomme de chemin pour que les gens
j'espère m'apprécie et comprennent que
je suis dans la même lignée que Monsieur
rot trop d'autosatisfaction affiché lors
de cette soirée pour l'opposition
socialiste emmené par Bernard ansard
pour lui la campagne des municipales de
mars 2014 a déjà commencé il a
d'ailleurs annoncé sa candidature nous
proposerons donc au Plaisirois un projet
alternatif qui essaiera de corriger
toutes les promesses qui n'ont pas été
tenues nous avons devant nous aussi un
grand sujet financier à traiter puisque
les les emprunts qui ont été renégociés
en 2008 mettent la ville quand même dans
une difficulté que nous aurons
vraisemblablement à gérer dans les 25
prochaines annéesnardar a déclaré sa
candidature ce soir alors est-ce que
c'était le moment opportun je ne sais
pas en tout cas il l'a choisi donc on
sait maintenant au moins on connaît au
moins maintenant deux des candidats de
de 2014 et euh ben on verra ce que nous
centriste nous ferons à ce moment-là
Joël Réau siège dorénavant tant 4 juin
il a annoncé qu'il ne serait pas présent
sur la liste de l'UMP ni sur aucune
autre en
2014 et vous étiez ému encore en
regardant ce sujet lors de votre
élection et et du départ même si cétait
pas vraiment un départ mais en tout cas
il n'est plus maire de la ville Joë rot
votre votre regard votre sentiment sur
ce sur ce passage de témoins ça fait
longtemps que vous y pensiez vous
l'aviez préparé vous l'aviez imaginé ce
moment oui bien sûr on l'avait on
l'avait imaginé on l'avait préparé
ensemble avec Monsieur Rignot euh ça ça
se prépare je veux dire c'est pas
quelque chose que l'on décide du jour au
lendemain ne serait-ce que parce que il
y a tout un accompagnement sur la
connaissance des dossiers sur la
pertinence aussi du choix le sien le
mien euh ce sont des réflexions c'est ce
sont des angoisses également je pense
qu'on a il faut prendre entièrement la
conscience de de la responsabilité parce
que ce sont des responsabilités donc oui
c'était bien préparé ému pourquoi ému
parce que parce que je trouve que c'est
un geste politique extraordinaire que
que d'être capable de partir alors que
tout va bien puisque c'est exactement ce
qui se passe monsieur Rignot s'en va
alors que son bilan est très positif que
certainement s'il se s'était représenté
en 2014 il aurait certainement fait un
très bon score donc c'est d'autant plus
beau je dirais de de de voir ce choix
qu'il a pu faire cé un grand monsieur
politique vraiment du côté de
l'opposition c'est pas le même discours
forcément qu'on tient on parle de
promesses qui n'ont pas été tenues on
parle de devant qui tourne d'inquiétude
du côté de de la majorité vous êtes
sereine avec la majorité aussi je suis
sereine parce que même si la ville aussi
est endettée on parle aussi de ville
très endetté du côté de l'opposition on
on met l'accent làdus bien sûr mais elle
est elle est endetté vous savez j'aime
pas trop parler du du du du passé mais
on est obligé de le dire si la ville est
endettée c'est parce que Monsieur R a dû
vous le dire plusieurs fois sur ce
plateau mais quand on est arrivé en 2001
la ville était surendettée à la limite
de la mise sous tutelle donc aujourd'hui
effectivement l'endettement est présent
bien baissé de plus de 20 millions par
rapport à ce que c'était donc le travail
le travail d'investissement a été très
important sur la ville pourquoi sereine
quelque part parce que tout ce que la
l'opposition demande aujourd'hui ou nous
reproche aujourd'hui de ne pas avoir
fait c'est justement toute une série
d'actions qui ne ne font que aggraver la
dette puisque ce sont des
investissements lourd qu'il est
impossible de prendre en charge
aujourd'hui à part si nous avons une
réflexion d'intercommunalité ce que nous
y réfléchirons dans quelques années mais
il est vrai ou dans quelques mois plutôt
mais il est vrai que toutes les demandes
de l'opposition sont des des demandes de
dépenses et on est plutôt nous dans une
régulation des choses au niveau de
plaisir c'est bien pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on a un budget qui est
tout à fait je dirait serein tout en
sachant qu'on a cette dette mais on a
quand même pas augmenté les impôts
depuis 12 ans faut quand même le je
reviens juste sur l'intercommunalité que
vous avez mentionné avec quelle commune
avec quelle intercommunalité 50 ans
neline par exemple par exemple pourquoi
pas non mais c'est sont des réflexions
vous le savez qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
réflexions qui sont faites au niveau de
des des des collectivités de la
préfecture on va pas se précipiter il y
a des vot choix vous avez une position
déjà sur ce dossier euh je dirais non
j'ai pas de préférence puisque
aujourd'hui j'ai pas j'ai pas de langue
de bois mais j'aurais tendance à vous
dire que il va falloir quand même
regarder l'intérêt général au niveau de
ce choix voilà et ce choix doit être
fait en bonne intelligence et en
concertation avec aussi les autres Maes
il est pas question que je prenne ou que
je dessine ou que je choisisse de façon
unilatérale un choix pour notre ville ch
plaisir faisait partie de
l'intercommunalité he de de C
quanttinou a très très longtemps
effectivement ça serait un retour aux
sources éventuellement mais il y a
d'autres perspectives qui sont également
en jeu et en réflexion actuellement et
nous allons bien évidemment y réfléchir
dans les mois qui viennent je reviens
sur le choix de Joel rot de de vous
passer la main de vous soutenir dans
dans le cadre de d'une nouvelle élection
au sein du conseil municipal de plaisir
vous n'étiez pas la première adjointe ça
peut être surprenant en général quand un
MRE passe la main en cours de mandat il
la passe à son premier adjoint ça se
fait effectivement C commun la
communication oui tout à fait ça se fait
mais je m'occupais également de gros
dossiers de dossiers importants au côté
de de Monsieur rot et puis et puis c'est
pas systématique effectivement que ce
soit le premier adjoint qui prenne la
place vous pouvez le constater même dans
d'autres communes vous avez abordé 2014
les élections de mars 2014 municipale
avec
non comme j'ai répondu à Monsieur hsard
l'autre jour est votre opposant
socialiste tout à fait maintenant encore
plus puisque je sais qu'il va présent
oui donc je suis ravi je me prépare je
suis tout excitée à l'idée qu'il va être
en face de nous vous serez candidate ah
oui je l' oui oui tout à fait je serai
candidate mais ce que je lui ai répondu
c'est que je suis pas du tout en
campagne et nous ne sommes pas en
campagne parce que nous travaillons
depuis 2001 et là on va continuer de
travailler jusquen 2013 fin 2013 et on
reparlera de la campagne quand ça sera
le moment c'est-à-dire au début des
années de de l'année 2014 vous êtes
candidate mais la campagne n'a pas
commencé sur la ville de plaisir bien s
que non vous attendez encore fin 2013
pour vous mettre en route même si les
choix vous travail à faire on a du
travail à faire candidate ça va être
difficile de dissocier les deux non
parce que je pense que qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'être en campagne c'est c'est
toute une série d'actions que vous
connaissez très bien on en a la preuve
là on a bien vu ce que c'était qu'une
campagne vous avez pu le constater mais
une campagne c'est c'est un moment très
précis aujourd'hui nous travaillons pour
la ville de plaisir et puis vous savez
il y a un an et demi c'est une volonté
effectivement de l'équipe et de ma part
mais vous savez il peut se passer
tellement de choses en un an et demi on
va travailler déjà on va apprendre à à
se connaître avec les Plaisirois
l'équipe qui est derrière moi est une
équipe extraordinaire et vraiment de
confiance elle a reporté sa confiance
sur ma sur ma candidature et sur mon
élection donc écoutez j'aurais tendance
à dire allons-y maintenant on va
travailler il y a de nombreuses communes
en ce moment dans le département des
évelines où il y a un changement la page
se tourne plusieurs mères ont passé la
main du côté de la verrière par exemple
du côté de maniléam aussi du côté de
plaisir vous l'avez entendu ce soir
est-ce que pour autant les habitants des
différentes communes ont déjà fait leur
choix pour les élections municipales
parce que derrière ces positions il y a
aussi des élections qui se préparent
alorsque le maire passe la main en cours
de de mandat est-ce que vous avez fait
votre choix pour les municipales quelle
que soit la commune d'ailleurs voici vos
réponses je crois que je vais garder le
même vote qu'avant et pourquoi et parce
que c'est comme ça et parce que c'est
mes opinions je vais certainement on
voter je sais pas encore pour qui on
verra je continue à voter comme je le
faisais avant parce que voilà j'ai j'ai
pas
de d'autres objectifs particuliier moi
je toujours vooté au même du même côté
donc je continuerai à voter du même côté
voilà si je vais voter j'ai une petite
idée pour qui mais je la garde pour moi
les gens savent déjà plus ou moins et en
tout cas on verra si les discussions
voons les qualifier comme ça par rapport
à l' chances qu'on a eu tout à l'heure
au sein de l'UMP vont ou pas avoir une
influence sur le scrutin une dernière
question votre dossier prioritaire avant
de rentrer en campagne il y en a
plusieurs sur la ville de plaisir on a
déjà à terminé ce qui a été enclenché
c'est-à-dire le gros dossier de l'Église
qui est quand même un un budget de de 5
millions d'euros et qui est une
réflexion totale de l'Église qui est
patrimoniale donc c'est un gros projet
puis nous avons d'autres projets
d'investissement très importants sur la
ville euh donc il y a pas un projet
prioritaire vous savez en fin de mandat
c'est un accompagnement des dossiers que
nous avons lancé début de mandat et on
va les accompagner jusqu'au bout donc
j'ai pas de dossierers prioritaires j'ai
des dossiers prioritaires merci
d'êtreevenu sur ce plateau vous êtes
donc la nouvelle maire de cette ville de
Plaisir maire UMP c'est important de le
souligner en ce moment puisque vous avez
également réagi aux différentes tensions
qui se déroule en ce moment autour du du
scrutin et vous devriez SZ candidate en
2014 vous nous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
pour les municipales le 78 se poursuit
on passe au sport